how many more bikes does bike world have
than bikes r us so let's compare bike
world to bikes r us
so bike world is right over here
and we see that bike world if we just
look at this
right over here bike world has 19 bikes
has 19 bikes and they wanted us to
compare
bike world to bikes r us and say how
many more bikes does bike world have
than bikes r us
so bike world has 19 how many does bikes
r us have this is bikes r us right over
here
bikes r us has
bikes r us has 12 bicycles
so how many more does bike world have
than bikes r us well we can just
subtract bikes r us's number of bikes
from bike worlds 19 minus 12. what is
that going to be
well if we look at the ones place nine
ones minus two ones is seven ones and
then one ten minus one ten is no tens i
could write no tens there but i don't
have to write that so there are seven
more bikes at bike world than bikes r us
and you can also see it here if you
start at
bikes r us if you started bikes rs and
you wanted to go
and you want to see how many more bikes
would i have to add to get to the same
number of bikes as bike world you would
see that you would have to go from 12 to
19 or you would have to add seven bikes
or that bike world has seven more
bicycles than bikes r us one two three
four five six seven
so how many more bikes does bike world
have than bikes r us it has seven more
bikes